hello everyone and welcome to a game
that was played yesterday in the
Croatian chess League between myself and
uh second category player Marion rodich
he uh did not play chess for some 10
years and now he decided to come back to
the chess and I was his first opponent
so yeah I actually knew this information
before we started the game as we had
coffee before uh so you know it's just
how we do things here and okay I didn't
prepare for the game uh all that all
that much because I don't want to like
overdo one line and then I get a
different line of them like okay now I
just have to start thinking so I I just
decided to start thinking right from at
the start from move one uh so let's
check it out I'm gonna show it from
Black's perspective and know for those
of you who are wondering the screen is
not cropped I'm actually just showing
the board for this video uh so uh let's
check it out it's gonna be a nice names
of Indian defense so let's see what
happened my opponent played Pawn to D4 I
played Knight F6 with C4 E6 and my
opponent played Knight to C3 he invites
uh into enemies of Indian defense and I
go for it so the names of Indian is on
the board and now we show this many many
times and there are many popular choices
here of course the most popular one
being Queen the C2 and pawn to E3 you
could play Pawn to A3 right away you
could go Bishop to G5 and the three
knights with knights the uh F3 is
possible F3 is possible the small
variation uh he went for Bishop to D2
and the problem with this is okay we all
know that this doesn't give white all
that much but uh I have no idea how to
play this so I actually thought this was
a very good choice by him so okay I
decided the development we have castles
because okay when I played the nimzo I
know I want the cast I want to play D5
C5 and B6 if he doesn't play anything
weird those will be my moves we have
Knight to F3 by him I played Pawn to D5
and now Pawn to E3 and I went for the
immediate C5 B6 is a bit more common
here but I went for C5 and now I closed
off my Bishop so I can go back and he
attacks at Pawn to A3 okay so I have to
capture Bishop captures and C3 and
Bishop captures and now we have this uh
weird position in the nimzo where he
actually still has his Bishop pair
usually you will uh and not see I mean
okay uh White will have the bishop pair
but you will not see this bishop on this
strong diagonal uh this early on in the
game so I really took my time here and
decided on how I want to continue do I
go for uh B6 and then just continue
developing like I know what's going on
because I don't and uh I decided against
it after some time I played Knight the
E4 and I I spent some 10 minutes here on
this position I think and I decided that
it was uh it wasn't all that great for
black if the bishop just stays alive on
C3 but just for fun I'm gonna show you
what happens if B6 is played as you can
play it I I was worried about the
captors and beat captures I've never
seen this uh with a semi-open B file
like this but let's say C captures e
captures you get this very funky line of
Bishop captures Queen captures you give
up the pawn on D5 he gives up the pawn
on B2 and now Rook to D1 so looks very
very good and now if the bishop gets
developed in White Castles then
obviously white will be perfectly fine
but if Bishop to B7 attacking my queen
you can pick up the pawn here Knight the
A6 and now let's say queen to A5 uh you
will get this position let's say B6 uh
captures capture saying okay he's up a
pawn but the A3 Pawn is a little bit
weak so you should not have a problem uh
reclaiming that but I had no idea how to
play this I played Knight to the E4 and
it is in fact the most common move
played in this position
uh last time it was played in in a top
tier game uh on the and even on the
absolute highest level uh Anand played
it against the Levon Ariana in the
London chess classic 2015 their game
ended in a draw uh and usually you just
want to defend the bishop there's no
good Square for the bishop to move so
you're gonna play Rook to C1 or queen to
C2 my opponent on the other hand play
the D captures in C5 and it is not as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game and uh well I I thought about this
move I thought he might play it but I
didn't really care all that much I just
tripled his pawns Knight captures beat
captures and I played Queen to A5 now
just you know getting ready to reclaim
my material and hopefully get a nice
position out of it he played Queen to C2
and I uh I thought about recapturing
right away but uh or maybe some Knight
to A6 file By Night captures on C5 but I
went for Bishop to D7 first as I thought
okay his Queen is on C2 I might as well
uh get a nice Square for my Bishop with
Tempo he played C captures on D5 and I
played Bishop A4 okay attack is Queen
nothing spectacular he played Queen to
B2 okay he does put pressure on my B7
Pawn but he can never capture it while
the C3 Pawn is hanging and now how do I
continue here I I could of course
capture on the five but I was afraid
that if I capture right away that Queen
to B4 and I really don't have all that
much to show for
as I did sacrifice uh a pawn here but
okay I could continue Knight to C6 and
it captures captures he will always have
the Double C Pawn to worry about and uh
well I can well double rocks on the C
file and start uh collecting material uh
but I went for Knights the A6 right away
for the moment stopping Queen to B4 and
kind of hoping that he plays Bishop
captures uh Knight on A6 and to my
surprise that's exactly what he played I
did thought I did think about what if he
just plays D6 is this maybe too too
strong uh but okay I can capture on C5
and if Queen to B4 uh yes he does have a
past the D Pawn but I can just you know
do whatever let's say queen capture say
captures and uh still he has a a c Pawn
he has an isolated a pawn and I'm
probably gonna be able to win them back
so instead after Knight to A6 he played
Bishop captures on A6 and I thought this
was very weird because uh I played Queen
captures on A6 and now how is he going
to Castle he played the D captures on E6
and it's perfectly fine strongest move
recommend ended by the engine I played F
characters on E6 and now uh how do you
continue here he played Queen to E2 he
offered an exchange of queens and I
thought okay is this a little bit weird
what am I missing here uh I could just
play Bishop to B5 and I stop him from
castling pretty much indefinitely but
then I thought okay he probably wants to
somehow attack my Bishop with the Knight
he wants to include the Knight and also
once I move my Bishop he gets the D1
Square for his Rook so he also gets to
activate his Rook but obviously I'm not
gonna trade I gave up a pawn for this um
even two pawns so I'm just gonna play
Bishop to B5 I chase away the queen he
moved the queen back now okay he can
maybe put some pressure on that bishop
and I played Rook 8 to d8 and now I
thought okay I have uh immense pressure
on this diagonal I have pressure on this
uh f file and I have pressure on the D
file I I like my position very much but
then he threw in another move that
surprised me pawn to A4 and just such a
ugly move to see I mean where where do I
put my Bishop now
obviously I'm not going to capture if I
capture with Bishop captures he can do a
lot of moves like even Queen Day 2 is
just a very annoying attacking the
bishop and putting pressure on the E6
Pawn uh how do you defend here you have
to move the bishop trade queens and
nothing really happening here and I
wanted to keep my position active so I
played Bishop to see no I thought about
Bishop to C6 obviously it's very nice
but uh I was fearing uh Knight to D4 and
now even if I capture on G2 and he plays
Rook G1 and I move the bishop back uh
doesn't look like something I want to
commit to long term so instead after
this um A4 move I played Bishop to C4 I
did think about Bishop to D3 but I
decided against it as it blocks my Rook
uh so he played Knights the D2 attacking
my bishop and I played Rook to F5 I just
I decided that if I play Bishop to D3
now then a pawn to F3 is very strong
he's just gonna play a king to F2 E4 get
his Rook into the game and he solved all
of his problems so I I didn't find a a
another way of doing this I thought
about Rook D5 because Rook D5 okay it
allows me to double up on the file while
still allowing me to double up on the D
file but I decided for this move instead
uh I have no idea why it's pretty much
the same move as I can still double up
on the file and uh on the D file I just
preferred this one for some reason uh I
actually have no idea why and he decided
for Knight captures on C4 now the
problem is uh if he plays Pawn to F3 now
I thought that uh now this rock cliff
would allow me Rook after D5 going for
his Knight and that this wasn't all that
great for him and indeed with best play
it's probably gonna be a draw because
after Knight to E4 I have no way of
actually stopping King F2 I have to play
Bishop to D3 to attack the Knight he's
gonna play Knight F2 to attack my Bishop
I'm gonna move back he's gonna move here
I'm gonna move back and he's gonna move
here looks like some sort of weird uh
repetition that I'm pretty sure neither
of us was interested in so he played
Knight captures on C4 I played Queen
characters and now he played Queen to C2
Queen to C2 I thought was a weird move I
I okay it does stop on the E5 and as I
really do want to play Pawn to E5 Pawn
to E4 but I thought maybe there are more
important moves that you could play here
so he played Rook F I played Rook after
D5 of course I double up here and I'm
very happy I'm still controlling this
diagonal I uh I'm preventing Rook Rook
to D1 I'm preparing some Rook to D3
moves I can never play Rook to D3
actually because once I play it he can
just Castle I I cut off my queen from
controlling this diagonal and okay I
mean I can capture these pawns but I
know I can always capture them so I'm
not really in a hurry to do that and
here uh he should uh play something like
Rook to B1 or maybe it's it's hard to
say or maybe start a Ponte A5 but it's
very hard to feel relaxed when you're
our King is stuck in the in the center
and you cannot move your roof so he
played Ponte H3 again I thought this was
weird maybe Pawn to H4 a little bit more
um uh precises uh you you can get the
Rook into the game somehow but he played
Pawn to H3 and this is a move I didn't
like because once he played Pawn to H3
he can no longer uh go for the plant
Pawn to F3 the problem is now I played
Ponte E5 and now if he tries Pawn to F3
now I can just play Queen H4 check and
this wins the game as uh now his King is
in a in a terrible situation uh and if
he blocks with the queen of course I can
just win it uh Rook D1 check row
captures Rook gives check and if the
king moves of course just captures
captures and Rook captures on H1 so
instead after Pawn to E5 he played Rook
the F1
I think uh basically for for the lack of
a better move he did not find a way on
how to continue in the game and I played
Pawn to E5 now just uh gaining more
control here and now I actually had no
idea what he could play and the uh if
you if you objectively check with the
engine there is nothing white can play
here he played Rook to B1 now trying to
go after the pawn here and I just
finished the game nicely with a nice uh
Rook to D2 and now there's no more no
more moves now I'm threatening Checkmate
he doesn't win my two Rooks captures
captures and captures but now that was
also kind of the point of me advancing
the pawn queen to D3 check and he was in
this position on move 26 that my
opponent resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here if you
go here I win this Rook if you go here I
win this rook and that's all there is uh
so it was a it was an okay game by me
but if we go all the way back at this
position where okay uh he did the
capture my uh Knight on A6 I sort of
prevented castling he played Decap F
captures there was a move that he could
play here in order uh not the uh not the
run into so much trouble uh so feel free
to pause the video and try to find
basically the only move that allows him
to keep some advantage in in form of
material while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
I'm just checking if the mic is working
guys uh I thought it's maybe not working
uh so uh for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on finding a
the only precise move in this tricky
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knights the
E5 this is the only move that uh uh that
uh gives him advantage in this position
I actually thought about the move I
thought about 94 I thought about 95 but
I thought that there's no way that you
could actually play this uh once I once
I cut his Kinko from castling I thought
that it was merely a matter of time
before I win the game but Knight the E5
would have posed a great trouble for me
because the idea behind Knight E5 is
that he wants to play C4 cut off my
queen and then just castle and there's
really no good way to tackle this if you
play uh Bishop to B5 okay I now control
the C4 Square we'll play Queen B4 and
there's no way to stop C4 that's the
idea you play C4 and you Castle so the
idea of Bishop to B5 is not really that
great so what you could play you could
play Rook a to C8 but the problem here
uh okay you want to start collecting
again is Queen to B4 and now if you play
Queen to B5 there's really not much for
me to hope for Bishop character C4 will
again allow his uh King to cast like and
play real captors on C5 uh but now he's
gonna play F4 that's the point and this
is uh the uh these are the absolute top
engine moves for both white and black uh
so uh there's uh the problem is that I
can't capture the pawn now and regain
material because there's the fork of
Knight to D7 winning uh winning the
exchange so I would have to move the
bishop back it's the bishop to A4 okay
I'm still controlling some some space
here but after let's say Rook B1 going
after B7 I'm gonna play B6 he will play
King to E2 and he will get his Rook into
the game and we would basically have
this position where uh I would have a
bishop against the Knight but he would
be up a pawn and it's it's a clean Pawn
so he is better here not winning but it
would be it would be a Troublesome for
me uh the problem is after this F
captures an E6 move I uh I I did not of
course see all of this and I didn't
think that Knight D5 was such a big
problem I thought okay I I would
probably be able to find something but
also the problem is after Bishop to B5
and queen to B4 uh there's no good
Square for the bishop you cannot play a
bishop here you cannot play Bishop here
you can play Bishop to E2 sure it it's
it's a move but it doesn't do anything
it's it really doesn't do anything like
even a move like Rook to A2 is a is a
huge problem you will rotate two you
attack the bishop and uh
there's there's no good way to to keep
uh the bishop there it's just a uh just
a very very silly line that uh uh okay
you could go Bishop page five okay now
the Rook is kind of stuck here guarding
against Checkmate but now you just play
C4 you cut off my queen and you Castle
so you know even with uh with perfect
play uh he would be able to uh retain
the pawn and uh uh keep the extra Pawn
advantage and I would uh I would be the
one fighting for a draw in this game but
after he played Queen to E2 this
basically gives him a completely equal
position let me just check real quickly
what the engine says uh yeah it's like a
zero point zero zero zero point zero one
uh yeah he he dropped his Advantage
there but if he found Knight D5 uh it
would be a pretty tough game for me uh
so yeah I was a little bit lucky there
uh but like I said I I I I I I the pro
the the reason why I went for all of
this is because I couldn't find a way
for him to make some sort of an
advantage from this position so my
reasoning was there there was none when
in fact there was so I mean what do you
want to do uh yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and we've learned a
little bit about something uh how to
play the the bishop to D2 nimzo uh those
were all pretty much standard moves by
both him and myself so you know nothing
uh weird happening there only here after
the captures on C5 we went into new
territory but usually you just continue
developing Queen to C2 Rook to C1 or or
Bishop to E2 you castle and no funny
business is happening but he accepted
the challenge he wanted to grab a pawn
grab grab the second pawn and you know
in the end I was able to
um turn this into into my advantage uh
so I once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Bonbon
soul and baby boo girls niches
festival.org.gg uh Amanda Oliver the
most beautiful girl in the world Duncan
wine called and egbertian cheer horn for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else is happening in the Chess
World if you guys have any games that
you really enjoyed from the chess 960
event to use hashtag suggestion and I
will gladly go over them so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day